you know what the heck's it really like
to be a real race car driver my wife
actually asked me this question racing
for a hobby is a lot of fun
racing for a living
isn't fun at all it's a business
you know when i raced in in the cup
series
very very seldom
was i truly having fun unless you're
staying in victory lane now that's
always fun that's the goal right that's
the the day's end goal on sundays is to
be in victory lane but honestly if
you're not in victory lane it's not fun
it is it is very challenging it's hard
work it's
what you've invested your whole life
into and it's very serious and that's
the way racing was for me you know
i was very very seldom in a race car
ever out there you know everybody thinks
i'm just happy-go-lucky and and wild and
crazy not behind the wheel i was always
you know very very serious and didn't
didn't enjoy
um
the actual racing until it was over with
and you could get back with your friends
and stuff like that that doesn't mean
that i didn't always want to be at that
racetrack and
more importantly be in that race car
that was where
i guess my favorite place to be but when
i was competing for a living on that
stage
it wasn't fun for me it was dead serious
and and i meant every minute you know
every minute i was there if you wanted
to be if it if you say that it it's not
that you didn't want to be there um but
that wasn't necessarily your fun then
what was the driving force
i mean there has to be more than just
competing man it's always about
competition you know i love like did you
like passing did you like practicing and
making the car better oh my god did you
just ask if i like practicing there is
nobody in alive in the human form that
likes practicing no possible chance now
you like practicing i just didn't like
it when there was three-day practices
those were
terrible
practices six laps and
oh oh it looked like it was a really big
handful man thanks for not crashing my
car yeah thanks for trying to kill me
i'll bring it right back here and hey by
the way make another change so let's go
try it again that was fun let's go do
that again i like it over and over for
three days when they make really big
changes and then they're like hey we
just want to try this concept oh yeah
like just the concepts never that's
never a good terminology with an
engineer let's try this concept the code
feel it out was like hey this might be a
bag of [ __ ] but just like you know try
not to crash it but we want to try this
how do you feel something out in a race
car by the way in our cars the only way
they make grip is to go the speed that
they're designed to go so if you're if
if that thing's supposed to run 190
miles an hour and you're running 140
feeling it out it doesn't have any grip
so you have to go out there rifle that
thing off in the corner wide ass open
and go past the feeling out point the
only thing you're going to feel out is
your ass when it hits the wall as hard
as it does at 190 mile an hour that's
what you feel out then you get back
there and look at them cross side and
they're like
super sorry about that man i sure hope
you you're okay you're like yeah i guess
i will be next week yes that didn't work
yeah no [ __ ] sherlock
by the way those happen we've all had
those oh yeah yeah yeah i feel sometimes
it was again on the feeling out or or
you know a science project or something
like that
but on those you always feel bad for
that guy too because he's the one that
made that call and you'll come back in
and and
you know you see that guy and he's just
like
heads like
i'm so sorry man are you okay so i
always kind of felt bad for those guys
too yeah i guess adding 10 pounds to the
left didn't work
well it did until it didn't
yeah um so yeah but like what like more
about it like i feel like people just
it's hard to know about racing it's hard
to know what it's really like and you
know maybe even just like we could start
with like whether the car versus the
driver and
i always say that you know the drive the
car the best driver can't win with a bad
car but an average driver can win with
the best car
oh yeah absolutely and and that's that's
just spot on you know i mean i think
that's gospel as far as i'm concerned i
will say this and i don't want to go
away from thinking or push people to
think that i didn't enjoy myself out
there now the one thing that i did enjoy
more than anything
was passing people
it takes a lot of a lot of discipline a
lot of focus a lot of you know learning
studying somebody watching them make a
mistake pushing them to make that
mistake right putting that pressure on
somebody there's nothing more fun in a
race car when you're driving somebody
knowing that they're looking in the
mirror and they keep driving it off in
the corner harder and harder you're like
don't do it don't do it they drive it
off in there and next thing you know
they're sliding up the track and you got
them you know that's the best feeling in
the world being behind the wheel when
you force somebody else to make a
mistake because you were that much
better than them that day that's a cool
feeling so those days and those
circumstances in a race car were things
that i really did enjoy but
um you know the difference in the
drivers versus equipment
i think that's evolved too danica i
think when we first started or when i
first started
you know you had 900 horsepower that
thing would bite you yeah you were
trying to tell me my dad was telling me
that i was around in the 900 horsepower
days but i was like i don't know i
thought it was more like 700 but my dad
has better memory than me when did i
drop down
i mean my first year was in cup was 2013
really i would say 12 12. i think it was
like 14 or something 14 or 15.
so
you know
but i mean you're not 200 horsepower out
of cars i mean a lot of people that are
listening this podcast that's how much
their car makes totally
you know they took that away yeah so the
difference in driving styles you know i
really look at like a tony stewart or a
jimmy johnson they weren't quite as
immortal you know when those things
happen they came from no different than
me massive horsepower in a dirt car a
little bitty tire you know so you were
always driving that thing with your foot
you know and not necessarily steering it
with your foot all the way on the floor
today's day and age you're wide open
especially on a mile and a half track
you're literally wide open all the way
around and if you're hung out or loose
or anything else it's not because of the
adjustment in your pedal it's because
you're you're steering the thing and
you've got it loose with your chassis
and you're having to keep up with it
with the input in in your hands
that was something that really really
you know made me struggle with what i
was trying to accomplish behind the
wheel of a car you know when i couldn't
no longer balance the car so to speak
with my foot with the throttle um
it made you you know change everything
that basically you know that was
instilled from you from the beginning uh
and how i grew up and i believe that
tony stewart was the same way and jimmy
johnson again you put those guys back in
them fire breathing dragons and 900 950
horsepower
then go right back to the top i was
sitting in my office and i looked over
the reason i said that i was
i have 80d but i think i did i've never
been diagnosed but i'm pretty sure i do
jimmy's picture from eldora is on the
wall right behind you
and
i remember him getting in that car and
everybody thinking which i owned we went
to eldora he got in a dirt late model
and everybody including my brother like
man i don't know what you're thinking
here i don't know he ain't never been in
one of them i said watch he'll be the
guy to
got out there that picture right there
is a him and me standing in victory lane
it wasn't me that wanted it was him
i knew it like it's just that was that
when i raced against him in the cup
series him hanging that thing out and
using that throttle pedal to balance
that car it's what he's good at does
that come from dirt racing though like i
feel like i'm more off i drive off the
steering wheel and
not on the throttle so is that more like
pavement versus dirt
i definitely think it's a grip thing you
know dirt you're never gripped up ever
you're always sliding around on top of
the racetrack so you're balancing you
know that ball you're balancing that
thing um with with your throttle you
know a lot of times you're driving that
automobile with with the throttle and
the brakes way more than you are in the
steering wheels yeah
yeah i mean i coming from go-karting and
indy cars like i definitely drove off
the steering wheel more but yeah i mean
racing's just you know it's one of those
things it's like you know it's it's
you know the
biggest stupidest thing i ever said
um
stupidest thing i ever said is that the
indy 500 it was qualifying and it was
the first year i wasn't like in the top
10-ish basically and it was a struggle
like real struggle bus like i was
shaking when i got out of the car
because it was four laps on the
knife's edge which is not how you want
to run at indy flat out
for four laps which is two and a half
miles each lap which is 10.
um
and uh and i got out of the car and i
said i said it's not my fault
i never lived that down man i heard that
in at indy for years and years to come
not my fault not my fault but you know
at the end of the day it's like you know
the conversation we're having is that
it's if the car is good it's easy that's
the problem wait wait i mean you're only
as good as your equipment and that is
true
like
the best driver in the
prime example is kyle larson we both
love him 11 to death i love what he
accomplished this year i it was
record-breaking literally
record-breaking
but a lot of my friends that don't
necessarily know about racing
took to him i introduced him some of my
nashville friends like dude he's he's
killing it man our friend kyle like
you know all of them started calling me
and like hey mccool's personal close
personal friend kyle larson i'm like
dude [ __ ] no what are you talking
about
you know but that's they took to racing
because of kyle mcguise he's been racing
for five years in the cub series nah nah
nah nah this is first year like no no
he's been around a long time the
difference is he's in different
equipment that proves the point and it's
been proven time and time again but it's
not a knock to people either there's a
lot of effort there's a lot of
um you know there's just a lot of
infrastructure differences through all
the manufacturers oh yeah it could be
because you have a chevy version
yeah it plays right into the lap of of
said manufacturer and that comes you
know in cycles we all know that and
especially in our sport um
and but the brute honesty is it's all
about people it's always been about
people and no different in any other
business or any other thing in life
if you have the best people surrounding
you you're gonna look the best and
that's just the way it is you know kyle
larson has had the best team and the
best organization the best manufacturer
this year around him and
you know all the ingredients were there
and he put it together and was the man
you know and that's why i was happy for
him i think it was a timing thing and he
couldn't have timed it any better he
nailed it yeah it's cool to see too
after all of his struggles and
you know being out of the car and coming
back but
what do you think like i
i feel like i made
my probably my biggest mistake in racing
was
not spending more time with team
guys with
you know i just like for me it just i
look back and i'm like it wasn't fun i
didn't like hanging out the shop i
didn't like
you know i didn't and also like either
they were really old or really young and
it's either you know you're not gonna go
out to dinner with some like it's
inappropriate or it's just like i have
nothing in common with you and so i
don't know i look at it like that's
probably where my girl the girl in me
showed up a little bit it was just not
like if it was a group of girls i'm sure
i would have made friends with them but
i that was kind of my regret and i feel
like that
not a regret but that's something i
could have done better is get the team
to work around me so like how do you
create the environment because you can
have super talented
talented people but they're not inspired
right you can have talented people that
are not
putting in the right effort and so how
do you like what do you think is a as a
common theme with the years or the
teams and groups that you've had the
most success with well i mean i think
for you it was different i mean it just
was you know you were an attractive
female recently you just said it if
you're out with a young engineers you
guys are dating
automatic you know and the worst thing
about racing is how tight a circle that
is and it like literally oh my god
heavens forbid if you even get caught
talking to somebody like it's it's on
it's done it's official you might as
well put it to record books they're
they're full on dating and and that's
just the way it is so i couldn't imagine
of doing you know what you did all those
years being you know the female that you
were and ultimately it was you know a
pretty male dominant sport
um
for me though
it was always about that that was the
most fun you know my most fun memories
of before i got to nascar was driving
all over the country with the boys and
the truck you know the dually and
trailer and learning life and the life
lessons miss screwing up putting the
wrong fuel in the truck and being broke
down on the side of the road and trying
to pump that out oh [ __ ] don't tell dad
you know or or get off somewhere and we
about burn a motel down one time with a
bunch of guys we got drunk in the
parking lot started a guy's car and got
thrown out i mean like those are the
memories that like
you know you just can't replace but once
you get to this level and it's
professional side of it it was still
that way for me i had to have fun with
my guys and everybody had to have fun
the best year i ever had
was in 2012
back to that that incident with jeff
gordon that you were talking about at
the end of the year
we kicked ass we were really fast we
were knocking on the door for a
championship right down to the last race
of the year
and
took care of business but i'm telling
you
nobody and i mean nobody ever had as
much fun as we did doing it like it was
dangerous to go the track because back
then not only were you doing it you know
on on you know friday through sunday we
were testing all the time we'd leave
sunday and fly to
you know everybody always says why do
you idiots have your own planes i'll
tell you why because when i started if
you ask wanted to be home at all ever
during the week you better have a plane
or access to a plane because you would
leave sunday and fly straight to another
track somewhere in the united states you
would crack or test there for two days
and a lot of times you may go to another
track and test there before
you go to the next week's race wherever
that was like we were
all over the place that year and i'm
telling you in and out of cities that
we've never been to before having fun
and
that was a really really good time so
you know it's it's it's different
obviously you know you ask the question
but those are the memories and things
that i guess i was good at you know i
could make sure we may have a bad
weekend but i can make damn sure that
boys had a good time doing it um yeah
that's amazing yeah for sure you are and
you are
you are a
freaking good time like i have no doubt
that like being on you have any idea how
bad the headaches hurt anymore being
that good time everybody
when everybody expects that out of you
it's dangerous as hell i just want to go
to bed anymore and then what happens
when you and blake are together i mean
what happens is there have you ever had
to have your stomach pumped
first of all he's like 14 feet tall and
he's it's not fair like it's not the
same fuel tank you can't put it right
buddy same liver you're [ __ ]
i disagree with that there's no way a
human that big has the same liver as
mine and if his has to be enlarged it's
i'm telling you right now it has to no
it's shriveled it's there's nothing left
of it disagree disagree
if you ever
hung out with him a day you would you
would agree with me it's there's
something different there
wait clint are you drunk during this
interview
no i'm drinking water just kidding may
have put vodka in it but
that would be more fun i swear this is
copy
um no we've had some good times that
makes total sense i mean my best year
was probably 2009 in indycar
and my engineer my two engineers um we
didn't have we
we didn't have like a crew car crew
chief we called them engineers in
indycar and so there was a head engineer
an assistant engineer and um we just had
a freaking blast we laughed all the time
we we just had so much fun we gave each
other so much [ __ ] all the time and uh
that was my best year um and um funny
how that worked yeah it's true it's it's
been a hard it's a hard and hard thing
to execute like how do you make sure
that happens you know that's a that's
not an easy thing and i think that's
probably why it's hard to make the magic
happen no matter what sport you're in
speaking of sports from kansas how are
those chiefs doing
rocky road but that's chemistry what
you're talking about that's what that is
and it's hard to find and once you have
it it's hard to keep because everybody
else as a company you know when you're
in competition and everybody sees that
and realizes that
they need it you know that's what
happens in racing i see chemistry over
there with danikan or two engineers well
that guy's an assistant if i can make
that assistant
the main guy
pep him up a little bit i'm gonna pick
that away i'm gonna take away and knock
them down a little bit
that happens in racing all the time you
know it's very very hard to keep that
chemistry keep that team you know under
the same umbrella because next thing you
know somebody's pulled one piece of that
puzzle out it's just not the same